Let's pray together and seek the Lord for day 19,
Romans chapter 6.
Father, thank you for your Word. Thank you for what it tells us
is true. We could never trust our own hearts or our own
minds to tell us what is true about ourselves, but the Word of
God has told us who we are, and we thank you for it.
We praise you for Romans 6 telling us that we are dead
to sin with Jesus Christ, that we are
raised again with Him, that
just like He was raised up, we
are raised up. We rejoice, Lord. Thank you for bringing us
spiritual life. Thank you, Lord, for crushing
the control of sin over our bodies.
Thank you that at the moment that we were adopted into your
family and justified by faith and given a new holy life,
that there is no power on Earth who
can conquer us if we will fully appropriate what Christ has done
for us. So, Lord,
you have put this DNA, this DNA of freedom and
resurrection life and freedom from sin, death to
sin,
you have put this deep within us. Now, Lord, bring it to pass in our
lives.
I pray that you'd give us, Lord, a second moment of repentance for
sin. Lord, give us a second moment of
repentance for not just the actions of sin from
our past, but the nature that
birthed all of those actions of sin in our lives.
Lord, give us a second moment of surrender, of yielding of our bodies
and our hearts and our will.
Give us a second moment of faith, a moment to grasp
hold of what you say is true about us, of the DNA
you have implanted within our spiritual holy life,
and let us rise up and become what you've made us to be.
Lord, I pray that you let that be so in Jesus' name and for
His sake.
Let's continue seeking the Lord together in prayer.